pour moi c'était vraiment un grand
malheur d'avoir d'un côté des personnes
qui sont dans la faim et de l'autre des
pertes au niveau du gaspillage
alimentaire qui représente quand même 10
millions de tonnes par an
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle julliard mais je
suis la cofondatrice de l'association
l'économe que j'ai créée en démon 17 ha
le projet de l'économe est née autour de
la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire j'ai fait un constat un jour
en faisant mon marché habdomadaire avec
des producteurs qui avait plein de
fruits et légumes invendus en surplus
dont il ne savait pas quoi faire et en
leur posant la question je me suis
aperçu que les associations caritatives
ne captait pas ce genre de pertes et ne
pouvaient pas bénéficier de ces denrées
là pour pour les personnes qui se
nourrissent aux banques alimentaires
[Musique]
l'aventuré a commencé en collectant ces
fruits et légumes en surplus de
producteurs qu'on a tout simplement
distribuer aux associations caritatives
dans un second temps en 2018 on a
développé la fabrication de bocaux donc
de confiture au début pour se faire la
main avec la cuisine dans des
restaurants partenaires qui nous
prêtaient leurs espaces de laboratoire
puis en 2020 à force de côtoyer les
producteurs d'oeufs se rendre compte de
leurs besoins au niveau de la
transformation des fruits et légumes en
surplus on s'est dit qu'il serait
intéressant de créer une conserverie
mobile
[Musique]
donc une conserverie mobile laboratoire
de cuisine itinérant qui se déplacent
pour aller chez les producteurs et
transformer leurs surplus en bocaux donc
des bocaux à la fois sucré comme on
faisait avant avec les confitures mais
aussi des bocaux salée du coulis de
tomates des tartinades de courgettes
comme on fait aujourd'hui
courgettes ail basilic avec un petit peu
de citron on a pu faire des ratatouilles
du caviar d'aubergine et tout un tas de
recettes super sympa et donc ce sont les
producteurs une fois qu'on est venu chez
eux faire leur production qui revendent
ces bocaux sur leur circuit de
transformation donc salon de leur permet
d'éviter d'avoir des pertes ça leur
permet aussi d'avoir un retour financier
puisqu'ils revendre auprès de leur
clientèle ces bocaux là
[Musique]
on est en train d'un 6 et les tomates
parce qu'on doit faire de la confiture
de tomates donc et on va enlever la peau
du cou valentina allez passez à lalo
bouillante comme ça ça permet de bien
enlever la peau on enlève les pépins et
on regarde vraiment que la pub pour
avoir un bon produit à la fin
tous ces fruits et légumes pourquoi ils
sont
oui au gaspillage s'il ya plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est nous en
tant que consommateur quand on va chez
un producteur ou sur les marchés choisir
les fruits et légumes qu'on achète bas
on aime bien que nos fruits et légumes
il soit bien beau bien rond qu'on puisse
les garder une semaine à la maison et
donc on va pas choisir la courgette qui
est un peu plus abîmée par rapport aux
autres par exemple donc cette courge est
là malheureusement elle va être écarté
du circuit de consommation alors qu'elle
est tout à fait bonne qu'elle a
exactement les mêmes vitamines qu'une
autre et les mêmes apports nutritionnels
ensuite il ya les débouché commercial
des producteurs parfois les plans on va
rester sur la courgette les plans de
courgettes donne énormément de légumes
et donc ils ont pas forcément les
débouché commercial qui vont derrière
donc à une partie des courgettes qui
reste au chant et il y a quand même la
possibilité pour les producteurs de
valoriser en conserve dans des
conserveries qui sont fixes mais ça leur
demande de la logistique du temps c'est
pour ça que nous on est parti sur un
modèle itinérant l'idée c'était vraiment
de simplifier au maximum la logistique
des producteurs qui n'est pas utilisé de
leur temps pour ça est ce que le
gaspillage aussi en plus de denrées
perdu c'est des espaces de terre qui
sont mises à disposition pour ces
légumes qui ne sont finalement pas
consommer ces des quantités d'eaux
énormes qui sont utilisés pour arroser
ses légumes qui partent à la poubelle
etc de la force de travail du producteur
aussi qui est papa optimisée et pas
valorisées
[Musique]
le faire merci
nous ça nous permet quand même d'avoir
une maîtrise du produit ne maîtrise de
la recette on sait comment c'est fait
parce que c'est chez nous c'est fait
avec nôtre aussi fait avec mon produit
de a à z et voilà c'était vraiment notre
leitmotiv c'est un petit peu comme si
c'est nous qui faisions mais c'était
vraiment par des expertes donc en
général ces dépôts t2 de 60 81 kg de
produits là aujourd'hui nous font de la
confiture de tomates parce que c'est des
recettes sont pas forcément connus du
grand public et comme nous on se dit
steve vraiment un vente directe et des
produits un petit peu qui sortent de
l'ordinaire c'est parfait pour nous
c'est nous les invendus on a toujours
essayé de
de l'organiser il ya du gaspillage qui
se fait et même avec l'association
économe hélas on n'arrive pas à tendre
vers zéro c'est le mieux possible mais
il ya toujours ya toujours du surplus
par contre ça nous permet plus que c'est
des petites quantités de vraiment
essayer de trouver quelque chose qui
permettra qu'un jour peut-être ses
invendus n'existe plus
[Musique]
du coup les produits gagnent deux ans
voire trois ans vit quand même derrière
alors au quotidien si je peux vous
donner un conseil ce serait de ne pas
hésiter à acheter les fruits et légumes
moche qui soit dit forme un peu tordu un
peu abîmée c'est pas grave c'est tout
aussi bon et vous ferez une bonne action
et chez vous il ya plein de méthode pour
que vous puissiez valoriser les vieux
fruits et légumes de votre frigo
que ce soit en confiture maison que ce
soit en salade de fruits un souple il ya
vraiment plein de méthode et vous pouvez
trouver plein d'astuces sur internet sur
l'anti gaspillage et toi qu'est ce que
tu fais contre le gaspillage alimentaire
[Musique]